Ga Ga Gah!
Hey, how'd you know that old ratty cop
out there? Or whatever?
So we're back to this now.
Fine. I can play the quiet game too.
Why won't you talk?
Why won't you talk? Why won't you talk?
Why do you talk so much.
This mouth has gotten me out of a lot of
sticky situations.
Ew. Not like that?
I mean, that happened to.
Out here. Silence can get you killed.
Silence kept me alive.
Oh, yeah?
So why would you tell that cop to eat
your ass?
Well, Hello. It's a mystery.
How our paths just keep crossing.
My men say that you have.
You have a darling voice.
I'm excited to hear what comes out of
it.
You need better f***ing friends, dude.
Go ahead. Drink up.
Oh, where we were sitting there once
flowed a powerful river.
Then they built this architectural
marvel. My father used to bring me here
for the tour when I was a child.
The tour? It's a bit dry.
Hah!
It's a little dam humor for you.
But now the roads have all become wild
rivers. So I'm building my own
blockade. A dam, if you will.
It runs from southern Arizona all the
way to the Canadian wastes.
But the only way through.
Is here. Wow.
Cool story.
There's been a misunderstanding.
All right? I'm not a criminal.
I'm a milkman on a delivery.
I know you got a beef with the girl.
That ain't got nothing to do with me,
right?
I don't give a f*** about your delivery.
What I do give a f*** about is how you
would happen to have this.
I have spent decades building outposts
and checkpoints, but this map manages
to avoid damn near every one.
I want the name of your cartographer.
My catero-- to what?
Your mapmaker.
Oh, no.
I found that on the side of the road.
Dude, come on.
You want it? Take it.
You really think I'm that stupid?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Not at all. I know how this world
works, Officer.
Little respect. I appreciate that.
But for the record, it's agent.
Even better. Agent Stone.
I didn't know this map avoided your
routes. I did not know.
Now I do know.
So how about I get one of those
licenses I keep hearing so much about
and I go on my merry way.
Go. Whoa! Why did you do that?
Oh, that was unnecessary.
Oh.
Couldn't even do it yourself.
We'll revisit that attitude in a few
hours.
I can't wait.
Get the name of the
mapmaker.
One leak could bring the whole dam down.